hop là si si ça lui fait un accord coupé
eh oui
voit fumer
je suis anglais 1
j'ai voyagé wendel un chargé
j'ai connu un homme qu'ils avaient
arrêté de fumer sociaux ne leur
connaissait pas c'est tout ce qu'il a
gagné
après circus santé
et chacun
c'est mon bail et
et
moi j'ai faim
oui
je
hanna reste là reste là à bouger ah oui
la bête
ben non
ça veut dire qu'il est moche et les
gentils et que les autres étaient là les
coraux et quand tu pars ce chat mort il
faut découper au ciseau ménage pas mais
je n'ai pas il arrête on va déconseiller
les bulletins stabilité
enfin des gosses et en dix ans a sauté à
la gorge des autres chiens
mais je pris de risque et celle ci à
cause de moi les douze communes et leurs
liens
un phénomène intéressant c'est le
racisme des français envers les chefs
religieux vous parler de racisme
approuvant d'angleterre h et anglais les
les anglais tout ce chien admirable
quand on passe le channel il s'est fait
insulter
andy stack aux chances d'un nouveau
stade ou dans un port
parce que d'habitude les français aiment
les becquets nicher
les bergers allemands en glace
informatisé
j'ai juste un vieux rêve il ya vingt ans
je veux un homme fort de l'année qui
mesure avec un seul restaurant et j'ai
cru voir une tapisserie moyenâgeuse un
chien mais on en voit un ancien pdg je
suis dit que j'aurais un jardin
j'achèterai si je réussis et jane le
seul a su tout petit alors écoute pu
retourner en angleterre puisque la
quarantaine et une fois je les ai perdus
en espagne alors heureusement il qu'un
en espagne ici on a une quinzaine en
france est avec 15 en espagne on l'a
retrouvé grâce à une mission télévision
on peut les photos j'étais atrocement
absolument fascinant avec ceux qui font
ces chiens là jamais méchante prince eh
bien j'ai cherché gg la police m'a aidé
les des taxis mon idée est sorti de
l'hôtel parce qu'une femme de chambre
ces ménages ont avancé par mois je me
suis dit je vais pas laisser un seul
enfermé à salles de bains sens pas bien
je vais à mettre sur mon dos et s'est
sauvé est bon il s'est passé huit jours
sans nouvelles
j'ai je suis rentré en france on m'a dit
votre seule chance de faire une émission
très importante au plus importante
émission des visions un talk show
émission d'interviews et réalisateur
espagne a été très gentil et m'a dit
écoutez on va parler ni de jenny de vous
en parler que du chien et le lendemain
j'étais alors couverte de tickets la
même et là encore des cicatrices est
malade mais c'est hésité à venir atteint
les les
les espagnols m'ont dit vous avez un
chien plaît c'est pas c'est pas l'argent
que je donne c'est pas l'argent qui
l'intéressent ne retrouva jamais ce jeu
mais je crois que j'ai jamais été aussi
malheureux depuis
mon père j'ai perdu ce chine je peux sur
moi je loge la muscu vous avez vu je
passe les oreilles c'est vraiment écrit
un peu alors j'ai pas lu la déboute pied
fait mal mais dans ce débat là dessus
c'est l'oxygène nana oui hélas ne
quittez pas c'est pour toi où vous vous
vous
vous pourrez comme les présenter qu'est
ce qu'une ici et d'autres à paris havas
est des bonbons et m
ben
habib ben oui ce chien a tourné dans mon
film là ce que j'ai trouvé qu'il
je suis en politique est très bien vu le
sujet j'apparais ardennes
bonne actrice mais voilà regarder qu'une
fois la caméra elle avait une pâtée
production policière
vous avez des gens qui se promènent leur
chien
je dis que c'est pas le chien qui vous
de la lesse et de m